en tournée c'est pas de la cuisine c'est
pas un truc de coupe il ya aucune
innovation une oreillette mais on a déjà
vu ça dit fois je vois pas où vous
trouver la moindre qualité des vrais
gens alors messieurs il vient de me
donner une idée alors peut-être l'aider
à la con mais on va la tester jules
verne s deviendra alors un pied quoi
j'étais de régime vers des gens que
j'aime et abba dont gilles verdez vous
allez en régie je vais prendre quelqu'un
dans pluie je lui met une oreillette et
la personne va devoir dire tout ce que
vous lui dites sur les admissions fille
s'y attarder gad elmaleh dans
l'oreillette de thierry moreau que toi
le sens large et bonnes vannes on va
prendre quelqu'un on va quand les gars
on va prendre on va prendre déjà ce
monsieur ce monsieur bonnet monsieur
bonnet monsieur
[Musique]
mais voilà passe de gilles ça j'aime
beaucoup ce que ça va être bon alors on
va vous équipez vous allez voir comme
gilles verdez je vous donne un mini déjà
vieille de dire quand vous appelez la
merci un peu ça fait plaisir de voir
gérard louvin ça fait long merci bonjour
quel est votre prénom viguier didier
bonsoir vous faites quoi dans la vie
dédiée retraite dit j'ai l'impression
que tu me manques sont retraités
je vous met une oreillette didier est ce
que je peux vous mettre ça dans
l'orifice oui ça va ça fait pas trop mal
il est aussi didier vous êtes content
d'être avec nous oui je peux vous faire
un petit bisou
oui ça si je peux dire merci merci
d'être là car c'est vous est donné avec
qui elle doit de faire de votre fille
vous savez que vous allez devoir dire
tout ce que vous dit gilles verdez donc
a priori vous repartirez sans votre
fameux sans votre équipe au complètement
didier et vous allez voir gilles verdez
on va continuer à parler télé et vous
dira des trucs au raid et qui vous dit
un truc vous levez la main un bien sûr
et vous le dit voilà c'est pas si
mauvais concept que ça en fait
alors allez-y va continuer alors n'ont
pas joué du tout la comédie et ils
s'entendent très bien
didier louis moreau vous n'êtes pas
crédible c'est pour télé 7 jours
[Rires]
il est pénible parce que ça où
travaillait et seydou bouda épouse
avaient peur aussi ken pokora mika the
voice vous refuse la couvrir parce que
nous venons chaque année c'est pareil de
toute façon chaque année dès qu'un
lancement de the voice
une embrouille entre un coach et un
autre coach ou alors une histoire
d'amour entre un candidat et un coach
c'est toujours pareil quoi toujours
pareil capucine te faire ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
à
dans votre vie tu vas le regretter parce
que déjà maire d'eze il est pas très
animé mais la sorte et au moins une âme
ne serait rien à l'émission et je ne
vois pas ce qu'il apporte enfin il
apporterait rien en plus par rapport aux
jurés actuelle rien dire mais tu es mort
on voit attaquer mr di meco psp go pour
attaquer mr gibbs en malaisie que je
voulais
[Rires]
alors que je voulais dire handley m'a
dit alors que si vous voulez dire
quitter boro pour engueuler mr bean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mr bean games d'idées il trouve qu'ils
rentrent pas effectivement un petit peu
dans le cahier des charges très bons ils
disent n'importe quoi une fois que je
t'aime ces questions à tous pas touche
[Applaudissements]
oui merci ah non ça serait bien si elle
n'était plus là dans tpm paix ça me
manquerait beaucoup parce que c'est une
chronique heures hors pair une chronique
locale tandis que et si l'eau au niveau
du français ont des commandes
merci didier qu'est-ce qui est cheikh
mourou ce soir après c'est vrai que elle
est hyper bonne en tant que chroniqueuse
sûreté pmp si elle part ça va beaucoup
manquer quand elle n'est pas là en
chroniqueuse je trouve que je trouve
qu'elle manque parce que elle dit ce
qu'elle pensait les caches et la vraie
question c'est est ce que les gens ont
envie de deux arrêts de fer ou de bois
et ta copine didier vous avez quelque
chose à dire a ajouté je crois
enora j't'adore moi aussi je t'adore dj
gilles dorment à mon gars parlent les
autres vous êtes une bonne dose
remarquent
c'est
il la comédie la première fois les
autres vous êtes une bande de renards
on vous dira où on met quoi suis pas
d'accord avec vous c'est que je veux
qu'elle reste la touche pas à mon poste
mais je suis persuadé qu'un format
décalé de la temps guidé ya déjà de
vernis cause du faux caresser de leurs
mots qu'il faut dégager ces de c2c de
lanvaux qu'il faut dégager
j'aurais pu faire les anges il n'a pas
l'air d'ignorer sa bogossitude regarde
être conscient de l'audace
oui didier pendant ce mec j'ai un
blaireau sa joie oui alors vous j'ai vu
l'émission c'est vrai que des gens comme
moi tienne 10 minutes devant lui ah oui
mais en plus
pardonnez-moi la bogossitude nomme on
peut la naissance on peut la vie ce qui
passe à venir coiffer n 10 minutes et
donc il va faire le buzz j'habite
auteurs mais effectivement on va en
parler dans les mythes et les gars
jusqu'au m de gains sur le plateau qui
sont crus de top gun à vous d'avoir
hacké le réalisateur basse et igor et
grichka à bercy oui bah merci les
turbines moeurs affirme que tu as eu
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
isabelle est ce que c'est vrai non pas
du tout bref vous avez vous est il est
fou mais alors je vous jure que c'est
vrai et c'est pas la première fois qu'on
voit ce tweet ah mais non mais non mais
je suis désolé mais non ces braves
canidés
si c'est vrai c'est raté
là dedans non plus énorme parce qu'ils
ont bien joué vous ici père persuadé et
viennent d'ailleurs retournée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
baptisé aller à sud de capucine
inspirent les internautes
[Musique]